hello I'm Martha Stewart I've written
several cookbooks today I'd like to talk
a few about the other cookstove
celebrity ships performers prime
ministers and even royalty have joined
the argA Club there's something
exceptional about the design of the Aria
the secret to the cookers success is its
dense cast-iron shell which absorbs and
retains heat so food is cooked by
radiant heat not heated air in the last
10 years is a big switch in the fuel
type used by the RV to go from having
oil and gas in to having real product
that is largely electric about
two-thirds of ours today or electric
Swedish physicist Gustav darlin invented
the all-in-one cooker in 1922 it was
brought to Britain in the 30s and
reinvented by a team of engineers and
marketers the earliest and most
successful salesman original ad man and
world war ii spy David Ogilvy augers are
made in the original foundry in the
English Midlands assembled by hand sales
plummeted during the recession forcing
the company to layoff a fifth of its
workers it's been a tough few years but
on the factory floor transition is afoot
these new cookers contain electronics
unlike traditional augers they turn on
and off controlled by a smartphone and
they're selling i think the modern agro
actually is the best of the price we've
ever made and that's why we think arrgh
you can go from being a successful niche
UK brand to this global product
you